hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
I just read a really good dreadlock for
article from last week it's really good
it's linked below you should check it
out and I've done a lot of smart phone
videos on this channel especially lately
there's a few really big ones coming up
soon and for those who have watched
those smartphone videos or basically any
videos about tech on YouTube you've
probably noticed smartphones have gotten
really good lately they've gotten
cameras so good they're borderline
replacing pointing shoots have gotten
screens so good that they eclipsed the
resolutions we had on laptops and TVs a
couple years ago these parts are
incredibly good in an incredibly small
package but there always seems to be a
but to deter someone from buying a
smartphone there's always one like
critical flaw with basically every
smartphone out there that could affect a
buying decision this is probably
something you've run into if you're
trying to buy a smartphone if your
smartphone shopping right now or if
you're someone like me who's constantly
asked to recommend a smartphone to buy
the over I guess yo dude I just broke my
phone and I need to get a new one what
is the best smartphone out there best
out right now I would say a samsung
galaxy s6 right great build awesome
camera one of the best screens on any
phone it's fast great build materials
can't really go wrong alright but it
does have pretty bad battery life yeah
yeah it's one of those small like really
small sealed in batteries so it's
usually gonna die before the end of the
day on me but and also no expanding
storage it's also not water-resistant so
alright you know what
LG g4 great phone high-end specs has a
great build has a great screen has a
great camera and the back is removable
so you get your microSD card slot
but LG's software is really not by Cray
like just as a warning and they like so
far behind on updates actually know it
here Nexus 6 boom easy stock Android the
latest and greatest software always up
to date there's your winner it's always
to put yeah you're right this one's way
too big for a normal person if you know
what what are you coming from now motive
Droid Motorola phone
yeah er turbo right so yeah moto you'll
be okay with the newest Motorola phone
the Moto X play comes out soon should
have a huge battery great new screen new
camera updated specs near stock Android
it doesn't come out of the United States
or you drop to the 1 + 2 or that doesn't
have NFC though or you go just go note
note 5 or no sorry it's still huge also
doesn't have an SD card slot and no IR
blaster ok
what is the solid all-around good phone
actually you know what it's good I'll
just get an iPhone so at the end of the
day what do we learn obviously there's a
critical flaw in pretty much every
smartphone out there that can affect a
buying decision this isn't to say that
smartphones aren't good they're really
good but they're not perfect and I don't
think there will ever be anything that
we can actually call in real life the
perfect smartphone mostly because the
definition of this perfect elusive
smartphone is actually changing it
evolves what we expect and what we've
come to know in a top to your smartphone
has evolved and changed every year and
even month-to-month
now there is a pretty good baseline of
things that we all agree on I call it
the big four good performance
good battery life good display and good
camera and if you have all these things
you're probably a good package and a
good buy but then all it takes is one
little flaw a little missing piece to
make us reconsider if that's really the
complete package if we're really getting
a whole smartphone that we want
basically now we can measure smart
phones if you think about it by what's
wrong with them instead of what's right
with them meaning they get so much right
on the top end that there is entire
articles about why the galaxy note5
doesn't have an IR blaster or why the
oneplus 2 doesn't have NFC this is no no
means defending those decisions that's
just saying that if you get enough right
on the high end that those are the only
things you have left to write about
either way the hunt for the perfect
smartphone
will never die that's all we have hype
that's why we have comparison videos
that's why we have reviews that's why we
have the speculation about the next
version of a certain smartphone that's
yet to come out that's why we keep
seeing these dream smartphone videos
where we sort of piece together a
Frankenstein phone of all the different
parts of phones that we like that's why
next time you look at a rumor video or a
rumor roundup of a new device you
realize it's basically just a
speculation about whether or not it will
be the perfect smartphone that complete
package with everything we want but will
we ever see that I personally don't
think we're going to see the perfect
smartphone but what do you think
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
guys the next one peace
you